［ノック音］トントントン
大家さん）どうぞー
はじめ）あーすいません　失礼まーす
は）あーデーちゃんデーちゃん（犬の名前？）
は）いででで　いででで　いでで
は）新しいおうちにつきまして
本当にありがとうございました
大）いえいえいえいえ
大）まだ片付かないで申し訳ない
は）大丈夫っそんなことっ
は）本当しょうもない企画なんですけど
大）いえいえいえいえ全然全然
は）今日の企画の説明なんですけど
は）本当…大家さんにこんの…こんな
は）しょもないことに使って申し訳ないんですけど
大）いえいえい全然
は）あの僕の家に　大）うん
は）あっちのおうちに　大）はい
は）普通に座ってくださるだけで大丈夫です  大）はい
（犬：行きたいワンU・x・U）
大）はははｗｗｗｗ　は）犬は大丈夫ですｗ
大）（犬に向かって）はい大丈夫だって
は）なぜこれをするかと言いますと　大）うん
は）やっぱり今いろんな人が家でいるんですよ
大）はいはいはい
は）結構パソコンとかやってて　大）うん
は）皆んな仲良いんで
は）ちょっとアットホームな感じに
は）なってきちゃってるんですよ
は）まぁいいんですよ　別にいいんですけど
は）たまにこうピリッとした緊張感    大）わかります
大）あのー
は）みなぎる緊張感ですｗ
は）普段間違いなく僕の家に大家さんが
は）居ることはないので
は）その非現実を　大）はい
は）ちょっとみなさんに刺激的に
は）体感していただきたいということで　大）はい
は）あっ　別にｗそ％＆’＊〜ｗｗ
大）いやいやいやｗｗｗ
は）えっぉぉええ
は）おはよう
は）よーしよしよし
子犬）キュゥゥゥン
は）うわー
は）おうちにこっそり大家さんが突然いて
普通に生活してるドッキリ
は）やって行きましょうｗｗｗ
だいちぃ）えっ！えっ？
だいちぃ）えっ！えっ？×２
だいちぃ）えっ！えっ？×３
だいちぃ）えっ！えっ？×４
だいちぃ）えっ！えっ？×５
だ）びっくりした
だ）え？え？
だ）ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
だ・は）ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
は）じゃ今皆んな行ったんで
は）コタツの部屋で
大）下だよね？　は）はい、あ、上でございます
は）すげー
は）あ、ここです
は）おつかれーっす×４
（ギロッ）
は）やふへゐ（ようへい）くーん
やふへゐ先生）はーい
は）え？今うちにいたのびっくりしませんでしたか？
や）いやなんかもう
は・大）ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
や）触れない方がいいのかなって
は）ちょっとたなっちきたからやばい
たなっち）（声にならずに驚く）
た）ねーねーねーねー
た）やばいってぇ〜
は）ｗｗｗｗ
た）ねーやばいってこれは
た）すっげーびっくりした今
は）お疲れ様です　ありがとうございました
大）ありがとうございましたｗｗ
は）はいというわけで
大家さんが突然家にいるドッキリでした
た）いやーくっそー　は）はははｗｗｗ
た）おどかすとかより全然びっくりしますよ
大）あっそうなんだー
は）やっぱ非日常ですからね大家さんが家にいr
【はじめしゃちょーのエンディング】